alors est-ce que la mort de mon frère a
servit à quelque chose si ça avait
servit à quelque chose peut-être que
Monsieur Dominique Bernard sera sera
encore là donc je pense qu'effectivement
les mesures n'ont pas du tout été prises
puisque l'affaire de mon frère n'a
absolument pas été analysée parce qu'il
faut quand même comprendre que ce qui
arriva à mon frère on peut effectivement
pointer des responsabilités à droite à
gauche mais c'est surtout comprendre
l'entrisme islamique qui est à l'actuel
dans nos écoles et qui prend de plus en
plus de place et que
si c'est pas entre guillemets une menace
de décapitation ça on va passer à la
menace d'une bombe la société est devenu
un chaos en fait à l'heure actuelle donc
par rapport donc aux revendications donc
des élèves ou des parents d'élèves qui
peuvent être menaçants donc
effectivement ce qu'il faut surtout donc
ça retourne sur l'islamisme faut faut
mener un combat idéologique parce que en
fin de compte les mesures correctives on
va protéger un professeur évincer un
élève le mettre dans un ement on va
faire convoquer le père de famille qui a
pu menacer et qui sera jugé souvent sous
des peines qui sont tout à fait
négligeable donc en fin de compte ça
entraîne récidive parce qu'en fait on
déplace les problèmes c'est un petit peu
comme si on appuyait sur un cancer et
qu'on disème des cellules cancéreuses un
petit peu partout par rapport à ça pour
moi c'est c'est vraiment un combat que
tout le monde doit mener contre
l'islamisme à l'heure actuelle qui
effectivement est en pleine offensive et
qui va de plus en plus
vite
[Musique]